اسابيع من الكاري والفرو وتقدما ميزني
اوكرا بالتزامن مع اجلاء موسكو المدنيين
في مقاطعه خرسون جاء اعلان وزير الدفاع
الروسي سارق اشويغو عن انسحاب القوات
الروسيه من الضفه اليمنى لنهر برو في
خرسون ليطرح اسئله حولها هذا القرار خلصون
كانت من اول المدن الاستراتيجيه
الاوكرانيه التي سيطر عليها الرؤوس في
السادس عشر من شهر مارس الماضي مما دفع
خبراء لوصف الانسحاب الروسي بانه نقطه
تحول مهمه في مسار هذه الحرب قبل اعلان
الانسحاب الروسي بساعات اعلن عن مقتل
مسؤول روسي كبير يدعى كريم ستريمو صوف
بحديث كان ستريم سوف احد اشد المؤيدين لضم
موسكو لمنطقه خيرسون يعني خبراء عسكريون
ان هذا اياكس تراجع عن عسكريا الروسيا
امام التوغل الاوكراني في المنطقه فيما
يعتبر اخرون انا الانسحاب ربما يشكل
تكتيكا روسيا لاستدراج القوات الاخرانيه
نصبي الافخاخ امامها في المقابل ذهبت
تحليلات الاعتبار ما يحدث ربما مقدمه
للعوده لطاوله المفاوضات القوات الروسيه
التي سحبت من خرسون الى الضفه الغربيه من
نهر دنبرو بدات باستخدام اسلوب يعود الى
الحرب العالميه الثانيه يسمى انياب التنين
لوقف اي تقدم اوكرانيا المحتمل فما هي
انيابتني
[موسيقى]